well we are very happy that the uh
negotiations between turkey
and uh sweden and finland uh have uh
been successful and we are very happy
that uh we could announce the invitation
to our swedish and uh and finnish
friends
we hope that next week the accession
protocols can be signed during the north
atlantic council meeting
in brussels
and
then the ratification procedures can
start look first of all as a central
european country which is
located where it is located history
determines our house number
it was obvious for us that during peace
time
we have made our best in order to build
a pragmatic relationship
with russia
based on common respect
other countries have made the same as
well
and
of course a war period is totally
different from a peace
period
we do believe that we need to
we need to keep the
channels of communication still open
with russia
because if we close these communication
channels then we basically say that we
give up our hope in diplomacy
and i understand that current
circumstances do not encourage us too
much that there would be a solution
based on diplomacy but in the meantime i
do believe that we must not give up the
hope
and on the other hand if we uh
if we do not have such channels of
communication there's a much smaller
chance to avoid unintended escalations
because i think currently once again i'm
speaking on behalf of a neighboring
country of ukraine for us the the major
goal is uh to be left out from this
conflict meaning that we have to do
everything in order to avoid escalation
and we have to do everything in order to
avoid this conflict going beyond the
borders of ukraine because we are
neighbors and all minutes spent in and
with war in ukraine constitute a
security risk a hazard to hungary
obviously and did hungary come under
pressure from allies over your stance on
russian energy
well not here but uh in the european
union yes of course a lot
but we have to look at it uh in a
rational way
you know uh
safe supply of energy is not a matter of
philosophy or ideology or political
statement
safe supply of energy is a physical
issue
and if you do not have alternative
sources then you cannot cut your current
supply routes i think it's very very
obvious
so if we were not allowed to buy either
russian oil or russian gas
we would be physically unable to supply
our country in a safe manner and this is
something that no one could and should
expect from us
i guess so yes we do have to work on
diversification of course but we do have
to
be aware of the fact that this not
happens from today to tomorrow